chef Roxanne Spruance had competing
interests growing up in Chicago food and
field hockey a star athlete in high
school in college she also loved cooking
beginning a series of unpaid
apprenticeships in some of Chicago's top
dining restaurants by 22 she had already
become an executive chef in 2010 she
moved to New York and into the kitchens
of two renowned restaurants Wylie
Dufresne is legendary wd-50 and the
top-rated Blue Hill at Stone Barns and
last year she opened a place of her own
kingsley featuring creative French
American cuisine chef
Roxanne's Berlin's good morning welcome
to the dish good morning thank you for
having me tell us about what's on this
table yeah so we really focus on local
and seasonal cuisine we have a roasted
pork rack here we do all whole animal
in-house from local farms we also had
one of our specialties the grilled
octopus which we're serving with
cucumbers and heirloom tomatoes right
now and then we have our summer
vegetable salad with a white balsamic
and hazelnut vinaigrette
tell us about it it's a very handsome
looking drink this morning this is our
oaxaca smash cheers to that
I do yeah we muddle ginger with a spicy
agave the mezcal adds kind of a nice
like smokiness to it where did the love
of cooking and food come from for you I
grew up in downtown Chicago both of my
grandparents on both of my parents side
were terrible cooks not from them so my
96 year old grandmother still puts
pineapple and lime jell-o what's wrong
with that
absolutely and and so when I was growing
up my parents when they got together
kind of decided that they would start
cooking and so Julia Child was you know
a big part of that and so you know we
were baking bread we were at the farmers
market I kind of fell into it and one of
my dad's former students was working for
pork on at Blackbird and that's how I
kind of got my foot in the door when I
was 15 and so you were playing field
hockey in the summer but then going to
these hockey in the morning and then
going to the restaurant in the afternoon
right and then when it came time for
college though you played field hockey
but you also tell me was what was the
dual major environmental biology zoo all
and Fisheries and Wildlife which does
not feel like cooking it actually ties
in really well we work so closely with a
lot of local farmers it's nice to be
able to talk to fishermen about whether
they're using longline you know what's
going on with things like that what
brought you to New York eventually I got
offered a position at wd-50 on the Lower
East Side for wylie dufresne so I moved
out here in 2010 to work for him which
was really an enlightening and
eye-opening experience and from there
you went to Blue Hill at Stone Barns and
that was had to be really different it
was different being on the farm being at
that you know having a menu that isn't
even written being able to kind of
experiment and use this amazing produce
and ingredients that's kind of what
Kingsley has become you know we can only
do so much as chefs it really is based
on how good your ingredients are when
you start there was a great quote that I
read from you some girls plan their
weddings I plan my restaurant yeah I
mean but is this the sustainability that
you have at Kingsley is that what you
had in mind back then yeah always I mean
I you know even with the majors I was
always interested in the environment and
what goes on with that so I'm extremely
proud to say that Kingsley is a zero
landfill restaurant we produce a zero
trash everything is composted recycled a
whole animal utilization it really all
does tie in together and it's it's
become all of my interests kind of
smushed into one well it is the dish so
time for you to sign the dish and as
you're doing so we'll ask you if you
could have a meal with anyone past or
present who would it be I would have to
say Ruth Bader Ginsburg oh I think
that's our first vote first you know
yeah oh I love I love me some RBG I'm
sure she'd like to Roxanne's Bern thank
you thank you so much and for more on
Chef Spruance
and the dish you can head to our website
at CBS this morning calm